ça déménage à la librairie mille
feuilles de trappes la boutique
solidaire a quitté son petit local situé
près de la nationale pour s'installer au
23 de la rue pierre sémard dans une
ancienne maison de la presse à deux pas
de la gare désormais la responsable
emilie bertrand bénéficie d'une vitrine
passante et d'un espace mieux agencé
pour accueillir sa clientèle autre
nouveauté l'aménagement d'un espace
jeunesse de 20 m² l'espace ici il est
fait de façon à ce que les alors on a
conçu exprès pour que les mamans
puissent installer avec les petits les
mamans et les papas avec les plus petits
pendant que les grands vadrouille en
fait sur le reste de la salle donc c'est
vrai que ça ça fonctionne bien et ce
après beaucoup les enfants adorent venir
ici ça ça ça marche bien qu'ils aient
leur lieu au 6ème bien les apprécier dès
que les beaux jours arriveront des
lectures de contes devrait être organisé
dans le jardin attenant au total ce sont
70 m² dédiés à près de cinquante mille
livres d'occasion récupérer auprès de
particuliers et médiathèques du
territoire saint quentinois en partie
avec toujours la même politique de prix
compétitifs de 50 centimes le livre de
poche à 2 3 euros le grand format et
entre 5 et 10 euros le beau livre
l'autre spécificité de la librairie
mille feuilles et d'être un chantier
d'insertion une équipe de 12 personnes
bénéficient de contrats aidés financés
par l'état parmi eux ceux trappistes
chargé de mettre en vente une sélection
de livres de la boutique sur internet on
a de la chance quand même de trouver un
travail comme ça ça nous permet de nous
remettre dans le bon chemin et beaucoup
de soutien on a besoin pour notre
difficulté père de famille il aimerait
travailler dans la petite enfance car
l'objectif des contrats aidés et de
servir de tremplin pour s'insérer dans
la vie active des projets accompagnés
par une conseillère en insertion
professionnelle ainsi qu'une psychologue
pour ses douze employés au parcours de
vie parfois difficile ça peut être des
personnes qui ont en fait des accidents
de vie ça peut être des problèmes de
santé pour la plupart ils ont connu un
chômage de longue durée ou n'ont jamais
travaillé
france donc avec des difficultés aussi
pour certains de maîtriser parfaitement
la langue française la librairie
populaire et convivial prend également
soin de son public elle accueillera
dominique sampiero le 20 mars dans le
cadre du printemps des poètes